on
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
mode d'emploi aujourd'hui nous avons
rendez vous avec la gestion en
management analysée diriger gérer sont
les actes que les managers et dirigeants
doivent parfaitement maîtrisé mais la
gestion en management
qu'est ce que c'est exactement pour tout
comprendre je vous invite à feuilleter
avec moi le mode d'emploi la gestion
management c'est un peu comme au jeu
d'échecs
il faut savoir maîtriser différentes
tactiques et stratégies pour réussir
tout en tenant compte de ses propres
pions le maître du jeu c'est le manager
mais dans l'entreprise c'est qui
exactement
c'est quelqu'un qui est confronté à
l'incertitude de l'environnement et qui
doit mener une équipe à la victoire
les souvent assimilée aux chefs qui
prend les décisions et qui nous donne du
travail à manager c'est aussi un
animateur un gestionnaire l'équipe
malgré tout c'est en évolution ça change
beaucoup et l'arrivée de nouveaux jeunes
managers justement change un petit peu
le paradis du management
dans son ensemble manager va avoir et
des responsabilités qui peuvent être
très rares chutes mais surtout des
responsabilités en termes de réalisation
un certain nombre de missions
chacun attend quelque chose de différent
dans l'entreprise et le manager doit
être capable d'arbitrer entre ses
attentes contradictoires est différente
pour développer l'entreprise et la
rendre plus performante sur le long
terme
on a de plus en plus de managers qui
sans rien en faire plus de participatif
vers même des situations d'intelligence
collective et peut-être même
d'entreprise' d'errer dans plusieurs
années qu'ils sont et et nouveau courant
quand on qu'on découvre aujourd'hui avec
le jeune management la qualité
primordiale aujourd'hui c'est
l'entrepreneuriat c'est à dire on ne
peut pas être manager si on n'est pas
capable d'entreprendre
c'est à dire de d'avoir un objectif à
atteindre et de se donner les moyens de
l'atteindre en prenant des risques et en
assumant
les responsabilités par rapport à cette
prise de risque des grandes compétences
en intelligence émotionnelle et aussi en
analysant prise de hauteur pouvoir
considérer l'ensemble de l'environnement
et du macro environnement qui peut y
avoir autour de lui pour pouvoir prendre
les bonnes décisions au bon moment et
surtout ensuite de savoir partager cette
décision est aussi adapté son management
en fonction des personnes qui
l'empruntent de lui être à l écoute et
de pouvoir éventuellement changer sa
propre sa propre opinion
maintenant que vous en savez un petit
peu plus sur le vaste domaine du
management je vais vous invite à
découvrir l'institut supérieur du
management
ici à huy en cours que juste parvenir
votre sommaire spécialisé en formation
transversale dans le management il
essaime prépare aux licences et masters
mais également un parcours doctorale
grâce à son laboratoire de recherche
l'art croit mise en place par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
la maison de l'entreprise accompagner
les petites sociétés dans leur
développement
nous y découvrirons le management à
taïwan en plus de ces formations
diplômantes ou pas l'institut supérieur
de management permet aux étudiants de
profiter des travaux scientifiques de
l'équipe de recherche de laboratoires
l'arquois ce laboratoire est composé de
plus de 80 des chercheurs dont 50
doctorants c'est parti pour la visite à
l'institut supérieur de management
accueil 1300 étudiants chaque année dont
plus de 900 en alternance et plusieurs
centaines de stagiaires en formation
continue de la licence au doctorat
l'établissement propose 30 formations
diplômantes d'état qui ont toutes quatre
dimensions en commun
en global de l'organisation est donc une
approche transversale donc ça c'est un
point très important multidisciplinaire
être capable aussi bien de réfléchir sur
des aspects ou de voir des aspects qui
est marketing des aspects financiers des
aspects humains
troisième chose c'est c'est l'ancrage
professionnelle c'est-à-dire le fait que
à côté d'une formation théorique
il ya une dimension pratique et très
importantes et notamment à travers des
stages long des années de césure et des
formations en apprentissage en
alternance il y à une quatrième
dimension c'est à dimension
internationale et donc c'est d'avoir
aussi une ouverture importante sur la
dimension interculturelle du management
sur une approche une vision
internationale des enjeux et ça c'est
vraiment laid ce qui est commun toutes
nos formations des formations avec des
spécificités en fonction des
responsabilités que les étudiants seront
amenés à assumer tels que gestion des
ressources humaines gestion de projet
pilotage de la performance gestion des
achats ou bien encore management de la
qualité sécurité environnement
dylan a choisi de s'orienter dans lé
management stratégique et changement à
domaines variés qui peut lui ouvrir de
nombreuses portes ont fait du marketing
et du management
on fait de l'accompagnement au
changement du management qui soient
stratégiques opérationnels et donc ça
nous permet d'avoir un bagage assez
intéressant assez large et une vision
globale qui est nécessaire pour le
manager de demain
on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'intervenants professionnels qui
viennent nous donner des cours et donc
on voit des concepts mais aussi des
mises en application directe master nous
prépare réellement
avoir les compétences nécessaires pour
être un manager à développer son
leadership à savoir travailler avec tout
le monde
parce qu'une entreprise on travaille
beaucoup en groupe et on travaille
beaucoup d'acteurs
je pense que cet esprit critique et cet
esprit d'analysé
de collaboratif qu'on peut avoir dans ce
masters nous permettent d'avoir les
compétences nécessaires pour être un bon
manager de moi un esprit collaboratif
développé grâce à de nombreux travaux
dirigés en groupes qui permettent
d'allier la théorie à la pratique
on le voit par exemple avec le projet de
colocation qu'on va mal et pendant toute
l'année et aussi on a plein de court
quand la stratégie de la communication
globale le lobbing le cours
d'aujourd'hui qu'est le management de la
créativité qui nous qui en fait nous
donne plein de théorique on peut
appliquer par la suite dans nos
entreprises
il y est c'est m'organiser développe la
coopération universitaire et
institutionnels au plan européen et
international une approche indispensable
pour les futurs managers amené à
travailler de plus en plus à l'étranger
on est parti une semaine en bulgarie
dans le cadre du d'un coup qui est donc
le management international et
interculturel
on a pu la barre rencontrer
des étudiants bulgares on a aussi pu
voir le fonctionnement des universités
bulgare aussi le fonctionnement des
entreprises bulgares et également le
fonctionnement des entreprises
françaises implantées en vue qu'à
l'instruction de l'irm permet aux
étudiants par le biais de simulations
d'entretien d'apprendre à gérer des
situations concrètes comme les conflits
en entreprise
ce qu'on avait fait de leur enseigner
sait déjà que le conflit est inhérent au
fonctionnement des organisations quelle
que soit l'organisation il y aura
conflit
donc le conflit n'est pas un problème en
soi le conflit devrait être gérée donc
on est plus en effet plus de leur
apprendre à gérer les conflits
kdc qu'à essayer d'éviter que le conflit
n'est ce lié scène propose un parcours
doctorale grâce à son laboratoire de
recherche en sciences de gestion
ici on étudie le mode de fonctionnement
des entreprises en trois axes de
recherche à la gestion des ressources
humaines le management public et le
management stratégique et internationale
d'avoir un laboratoire de recherche en
management c'est fondamental aujourd'hui
c'est les pratiques dans les entreprises
se transforme les changes
grâce à quoi grâce à la recherche en
sciences de gestion
donc nous sommes au coeur de la
réflexion sur les coulisses de
l'entreprise sur la manière dont les
codes les règles et conventions les
mécanismes de coordination de contrôle
dans l'entreprise vont apparaître
donc on est on se situe en amont dans la
production de connaissances qui vont
être ensuite appliquée par les managers
d'entreprises ici une cinquantaine de
doctorants travaille régulièrement sur
différents types de sujets afin de
décrypter ces codes de l'entreprise
qu'elles soient françaises ou étrangères
c'est le cas de louis caleb et je
travaille sur les structures et les
filiales et japonaises donc exerce dans
le milieu européens travaillent sur les
contextes pratique
qu'est ce qu'ils font à l'intérieur de
leur entreprise et comment justement
cette pratique arriva n'est pas
forcément japonais et mais travaille sur
l'internationalisation de l'enseignement
supérieur et comment cet enseignement
fait face aux défis de la mondialisation
comment est ce qu'on peut j'ai le
changement donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut gérer à la fois les hommes les
structures et l'idée dans un contexte en
plein mouvement
donc effectivement toutes les théories
et tout tout ce qu'on peut apprendre en
termes de management et quand on
pratique ça n'a quant à elle a obtenu
son doctorat cette année là le diplôme
que j'eus un diplôme général en sciences
de gestion
mais ma spécialisation et la performance
l'innovation des entreprises ce qui lui
permet aujourd'hui d'intégrer le
laboratoire en tant qu'attaché
d'enseignement et de recherche
les doctorants sortant du laboratoire
l'arquois peuvent donc poursuivre une
carrière académique ou en entreprise
avec le titre de docteur pour faire du
conseil travaillé dans des cabinets
d'étude ou bien devenir praticiens de
haut niveau en ayant cette faculté
supplémentaires cette capacité
d'innovation de créativité qui manque
terriblement aux formations
traditionnelles 85 % des élèves qui
sortent de l'iace elle trouve un emploi
dans les six mois et même parfois avant
d'être diplômée dans les entreprises où
ils font leur apprentissage
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines présente la plus forte
concentration d'entreprises
après la défense une chance pour les
futurs managers qui souhaitent
travailler dans de grandes sociétés mais
également dans des structures de moins
de 50 salariés c'est justement un
management à taille humaine que nous
allons découvrir à la maison de
l'entreprise
mise en place par l'agglomération la
maison de l'entreprise aide les petites
sociétés et les pme de moins de 50
salariés à se développer
surya nagel un responsable du service
d'appui ressources humaines les
accompagne notamment sur le recrutement
ça reste malgré tout une problématique
que ce soit dans les grands groupes ou
en tout cas dans la tpe pme sur le
territoire de recruter les entreprises
veulent recruter locales plus
particulièrement et c'est aussi une des
grosses difficultés
c'est ici on a beaucoup de mal à attirer
les talents les forces vives est l'un
des axes du recrutement aujourd'hui
c'est de donner envie aux jeunes
managers de travailler dans une pme
avoir un poste de manager dans une dans
une pme
ce sera peut-être beaucoup plus
valorisant à terme que dans une grosse
structure plus de responsabilités plus
de champ d'action et puis vous êtes au
coeur de la stratégie même de
l'entreprise c'est à dire que quand vous
avez des plus en plus de haine +3 et de
+41 hérarchie sans fin c'est peut-être
plus difficile d'amener sa vision des
choses de proposer des projets qui
peuvent être intéressants et d'avoir une
ouverture d'esprit et une capacité à
faire valoir ses compétences dans une
pme que dans une multinationale la
maison de l'entreprise a mis en place
plusieurs dispositifs afin d'aider les
sociétés à recruter notamment au niveau
du sourcing en plus de l'apec et du pôle
emploi on travaille avec différents
réseaux sur le territoire et qui sont
amenés à rencontrer des candidats
soit en poste ou un poste à travailler
tout ce qui est prêt mais c'est notre
compétence donc on va dire un transvasez
des compétences des grosses structures
vers vers ces petites structures
et puis mon réseau la cvthèque que j'ai
pu établir depuis que je travaille sur
ce dispositif mettre en place aussi des
passerelles entre les structures qui
peuvent recruter et puis d'autres qui
peuvent aussi malheureusement licencier
leurs salariés au niveau du ch'ti qu on
a aussi toute une palette d'outils des
livres à disposition sur comment bien
mûres côté ou fait des ateliers aussi
sur ce sujet et sans oublier tout ce qui
est mise en relation avec les écoles
notamment l'institut supérieur de
management qui peut être un vivier non
négligeable pour les entreprises du
territoire
en sachant que la réussite d'une
entreprise dépend également beaucoup de
la personnalité de son manager c'est en
deux minutes consent de toute façon si
la personne pourra s'intégrer ou pas
dans la structure chez l'entreprise
connaît ses équipes et c'est ce qui peut
passer pas passer donc faut il que je
pense qu'il faut faire il faut faire
confiance à son intuition
ça c'est important les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui sont les managers de
demain alors pour les plus stratégiques
d'entre vous je vous abandonne aux
échecs
mais avant notez dans vos agendas la
possibilité d'autres tient individuel
sur toute information juridique lié au
droit du travail
ce sera le mercredi 12 juillet
uniquement sur rendez vous à la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
quant à moi je vous retrouve pour un
nouveau mode d'emploi et d'ici là prenez
soin de vous
oh
[Musique]
à